最近ねあの鳴子件を帰ろう買ったんですけどもなんと値段が2万5千円です今日は
ドクターズらー皆さん見ろ鉄砲って知ってますか
まあ知らないというと思う道を話しておくんですけども水が出る
鉄鋼のことです覚えておいてください水鉄砲って一回に出る量がなんかね僕のイメージ
だと結構少ないんですよ
チュッ
pot つ4本ネタじゃねー落ちこしこしてホックって出したら娘の胸じゃ見た
イメージなんですけど水鉄砲やっぱり米長量が多い方が絶対いいと思うんですよね僕
ちょっとあの簡易的な水鉄砲を妻が見つけましてこちらなんですけど
ワンダーフルポンプって言うみってこうです見たりすごいシンプルなんですけどこう
いう出場の形ですね
ペンタブのペン
水に入れて
といって水チャージして詰んでるんだと思うんでちょっと行くやってみましょうか
方法を結構入ったなぁプってみます
本当に撃つの
慎重なんだけど
動いてるんだもーん
ぶーという感じで一発で量は少ないんですけど威力がすごいですよねみました
パワーこれたくさん買ってきましたはいこれだけの水鉄砲ズームしました設け好き
でしょ
この水鉄砲普通の水鉄砲にはできない特殊なことができますそれ何か
合体ですと普通水鉄砲ってこんなから中のか経つとかなんで水鉄砲図書合体させにくい
ですけどもうこれ
スティック状なんでまとめやすいですよというわけで今日2水っぽいができない大量の
水でも合体させ
一発の排出成分量が史上最強の水鉄砲を作ろうと思います
そしてそれをはじめみゅーずめんとガーデン秋らしい人々に
分
[音楽]
ティガーをつくってみましょうガムテープでくっつけるだけなんですけどね
でくっつけていきましょう普通になるくっつきやすいと思うんですよをくっつけると
言わんばかりの形なんですよとりあえず3つずつまとめてガムテープで巻いていきます
ています
[音楽]
悪くないでここも本株テープ同じサイズじゃんここ幅がぴったりすぎて自分でも引くわ
これでも密度ず連発が出るんですけどこんな感じでこれを神服つけていこうと思いませ
ん
二つ三つの玉をどんどん作っていきましょう
[音楽]
10年前3つずつまとめることに成功しましたここからが勝負です次はこの3つずつに
固まったみずデポたちを
一つ if 使うくっつけますそういう感じだし
[音楽]
そうぜひたぞは3ドア目が世界社長の3つかねぇ
さあ
フープああああ
r
気持きもちよってもらえ飛ばないよ
まずこれを注水しなきゃいけないんで溢血と風水モードに入ります
久ゴールなしで潰しちゃってるのか勝ちました立体30これ
三宿の水鉄砲が一つに方しているので一方で全部水の量のさ二倍三倍鰤釣を一瞬で出す
ことができる史上最強の水鉄砲です私どれくらいの水分ヨーロッパ
例えばちょっとわからないんですけどもそれも本番で見てみましょうた爪はみゅーず
めんとたびに医療と子供は可愛いていますそんな彼らに僕は惹かれ休みしとなり水分を
与え彼らの人生肌として副
すべてよ
潤わせてあげましょう自分を受け取ってないヒルズにできるかがポイントになってき
ますねそういう方と言います
で1本ずつ衰亡していきます何ん
ちゃんと本柱されているとする
ていません
真ん中から良かったッ
ですねー
それはすべての水分を供給が完了しました果たしてどれくらいの o さんなの
でしょうか
思っておりますえっ
どうなってればいいまずようやってない500止めるんだよね
500と思ってないんですよちょっとまずは重すぎてキツイんでたぶんねなじみキロ
くらいあると思いますで早速始めアミューズメントパーセントエルバ島に水を
ぶっかけるのグラフィックだ
あっています
ん
んん
わーわー騒ぐ goo はぁ
ああああああ
[音楽]
ああああああああ
あた悪魔だよ